[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire l'opposition à la corrida
est aussi ancienne que la corrida
elle-même on lui a toujours reproché son
organisme sa barbarie sa cruauté sa
férocité sa violence aujourd'hui on
assiste sur la souffrance animale on
voit dans la tauromachie une longue
séance de torture plus ou moins
spectaculaires auxquelles le public se
rendrait pour s'amuser ou d'un pas aux
dépens d'une bête sans défense et c'est
à ce titre que l'on veut l'abolir alors
pour en débattre nous avons invité yanis
et ziadi vous êtes comédiens juste avant
la pandémie vous juillet dans fric-frac
mise en scène par michel fau au théâtre
de paris
et c'est vous qui vous êtes chargé du
dossier sur la corrida qui fait la
couverture du dernier numéro de causeur
sous le titre viva la corrida un art de
vivre en danger de mort vous y signer un
bel éloge de la tauromachie
y figurent également des aficionados
comme l'architecte rudy ricciotti où le
cuisinier pierre gagnaire mais aussi le
philosophe michel onfray pour qui la
corrida n'est qu'une mise en scène de la
maltraitance animale
une fiesta des patients triste alors
vous yanis si vous deviez définir la lco
reid en quelques mots vous diriez c'est
quoi la corrida pour quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais vu ça
la corrida pour moi c'est la rencontre
d'un homme avec son intelligence et la
conscience de lui-même et de la nature
de la force brute massive puissante et
c'est la beauté qui jaillit de cette
rencontre entre le raffinement et la
puissance brute c'est la manière dont un
homme par son intelligence et sa
conscience va modeler la nature et
réussir à tirer une oeuvre d'art va
réussir à attirer des des figures qui
vont faire jaillir de la beauté stratos
claire starozinski pardon vous êtes la
présidente de l'alliance anti-corrida
que vous avez fondé en 1994 qui milite
pour l'abolition de la tauromachie et
qui ai dit vos livres des livres tels
que la mort donnée en spectacle où la
face cachée des corridas si vous deviez
définir la corrida vous en quelques mots
ce serait lequel
il est un principe fondamental on n'a
pas le droit d'exercer des sévices ce
baiser ou l'amour la beauté des taureaux
ou encore leur survie il ne passera par
la nécessité de les suppliciés en public
pour ensuite les mettre à mort et le
monsieur qui viennent parler occulte
totalement la finalité de la corrida
il parle de barils parle de beauté mais
est ce qu'il a vu ce qui est vraiment
une corrida apparemment oui mais est-ce
qu'il avait eu ça parce que la corrida
c'est ça et c'est pas autre chose
c'est comme ça que ça se termine donc je
suis quand même su fait de voir que tout
ce côté là et totalement quitté julien
lescarret vous avez arrêté votre
carrière de torero en septembre 2012
vous aviez débuté dans l'arène quinze
ans auparavant en 1997 vous avez mise à
mort 300 euros environ ce qui vous a
valu 150 oreille et 4 que aujourd'hui
vous êtes insultant
en tauromachie et vous êtes l'auteur
d'un livre autobiographique au risque de
soi paru au diable vauvert vous qui
l'avez pratiqué si longtemps latélec
tauromachie voulait définiriez comment
aujourd'hui ça a été bon jour à tout ça
a été très bien résumé javon par yannis
grand chose à rajouter à cela est
effectivement c'est le hasard fait bien
les choses puisque je crois que tout le
monde le sait chacun moi j'avais pris
aussi quelque chose comme ça le plutôt
littéraire aimé y aller ça très bien dis
donc je vais pas enchaîner sur le côté
de l'histoire de l'homme du sauvage de
l'humanité parce que c'est le berceau de
nos émotions et de ce que nous sommes le
fondement même de nos vies et de notre
société aujourd'hui mais je dirais
plutôt que c'est pour moi un art de
vivre
c'est une passion qui est assez
tardivement à suivre mes parents et le
côté femme idéale évidemment aller au
fait aux arènes et vivre cette cet art
de vivre qui m'a comblé qui m'a rendu
très heureux et je n'occulte bien
évidemment pas du tout la mise à mort
qui fait partie de ce combat avec fin
voilà c'est une merveilleuse parabole de
notre vie et la mort je l' ai vécu je la
vis au quotidien
je la vis encore un petit peu en décalé
avec cette histoire qui me poursuit qui
me tiendra un avis je pense qu'on va le
peletier vous êtes historien et
philosophe des sciences vous êtes
l'auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
philosophiques sur la question animale
c'est sous votre direction entre autres
que son paru aux presses universitaires
de france
la révolution antispécistes et plus
récemment plaidoyer pour une viande sans
animal c'est paru exactement il y à un
mois vous définiriez la la tauromachie
de quelle manière vous bon très
simplement c'est là un spectacle de la
mise à mort d'un animal tout simplement
et rien que cette définition g20 pose un
certain nombre de questions alors il
faut rappeler quand on a le droit de
tuer des animaux d'élevage a notamment
pour se nourrir l'homme le fait sans
arrêt mais on n'a pas le droit de les
faire souffrir ses animaux est en tout
cas on n'a plus le droit et c'est de
placer autant maintenant nous en tant
que les gens ne le croient mais c'est
donc une des questions récurrentes
autour de la candy et de l'aide de la
corrida c'est est ce que le taureau
souffre de votre point de vue julien
lescarret
est ce que vous avez fait souffrir des
taureaux dans l'arène je n'ai jamais eu
cette sensation là je suis en plus comme
je vous ai dit fils de campagn'art de
paysans donc j'ai chassé j'ai péché glv
des animaux j'ai beaucoup d'animaux
domestiques et sauvages à la maison et
le fait de combattre des taureaux ne
jamais été pour voir une question de
souffrance alors je prends souvent
l'exemple de deux boxeurs qui vont
s'affronter qui sont dans le combat et
qui résiste mieux que personne au cou
alors à ce que ça peut susciter comme
douleur mais la souffrance et là c'est
là que je pense qu'on sera en désaccord
avec une zone habitée je ne la tribu ka
ka des hommes capables de réfléchir
cette douleur de pourquoi elle est bien
là de quel est cet acte qui me fait
aujourd'hui souffrir et que je ne
comprends pas ce qui n'est pas le cas du
taureau et deux mâles sauvage et qui
défendent sur l'instinct primaire car
starozinski pour vous le ton rôle
souffrent dans l'arène et bien
évidemment qu'il souffre d'ailleurs les
aficionados dizaine alors il a même
certains qui sans aller jusqu'à parler
de béton endorphines
qui arriverait à annihiler la douleur du
taureau mais c'est entièrement faux
puisque c'est une étude qui est mise en
avant par les afficheurs et qui n'a
jamais été validées scientifiquement
bien évidemment qu'il souffre vous
rendez compte
lorsqu'on perd fort là où d'un animal
que la pique arrive parfois à entrer
jusqu'à 37 cm de profondeur et on vous
dira que le taureau ne souffre pas ce
n'est pas moi qui dis 37 cm c'est ce
sont certains de hve taurine je les lui
lorsque je lis bien sûr monitoring donc
bien évidemment qu'il s'ouvre canton de
plants d arbres ou sept centimètres
quand on est en plantes 600 corps et
ensuite quand on les stocke quand on
pratique l'estocade avec une épée qui
malheureusement n'est jamais foudroyante
ou alors très rarement les paie entre
ressort j'ai vu moi des taureaux qui met
dix minutes pour s'écrouler
c'est absolument on se re et on nous
vous dire que le taureau ne souffre pas
alors il ya nice viennent et beaucoup ne
savent pas pourquoi on put le taureau
pourquoi le picador et l'ani pourquoi on
enfonce des bandes des rires alors tout
cela est très ritualisé tout cela une
fonction ça ne veut pas dire que le
taureau ne souffre pas d'ailleurs mais
ce que vous pouvez nous l'a rappelé et
ensuite vous reprendrez à notre à ma
question
mais moi le problème c'est que c'est
vrai que la physiologie animale et la
souffrance animale
c'est pas trop mon sujet c'est à dire
que moi c'est le spectacle qui m'a
bouleversé
ce que je tiens à dire en tout cas c'est
que si le public supporte et aime ce
spectacle c'est parce que ce que le
taureau montre n'est pas de la
souffrance
après on peut dire les aficionados se
trompent
mais les aficionados accepte ce
spectacle et l'aiment parce que le
taureau ne montre pas de souffrance a à
aucun instant on voit un taureau
souffrir
le spectacle n'est pas insupportable moi
le premier avant de connaître la corrida
j'étais un petit peu révulsé par cette
histoire de mise à mort de pics de bain
rires et quand je suis allé aux arènes
j'ai été obligé de constater que je
voyais un animal se battre dignement et
un animal ne ne pas souffrir vraiment si
j'avais vu si j'avais vu un animal
souffrir je vous assure que ce spectacle
moore est dégoûté et que j'en serais
parti et je pense que c'est la même
chose pour la plupart des aficionados je
repose la question à jeudi à lescar et
pour que pour que les gens qui n'aiment
pas la corrida qui ne la connaissent pas
comprennent pourquoi est ce qu'il ya un
picador pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des
bandes bérille
vous l'avez dit c'est très ritualisé il
ya des codes il ya des règles à
respecter
ce n'est pas un spectacle gratuit où on
vient simplement planté des banderilles
et vouloir faire mal à un taureau sans
aucun sens aucun sens tout ça est très
cohérent tout cas différentes hier je
vais pas vous nous passez tous les codes
de la corrida il ya différentes hier
qu'il nous faut respecter également y
compris l'engagement de la mise à mort
on ne se cache pas pour tuer on s'engage
on prend un risque et je rebondis sur ce
que disait ce qui d'ailleurs sur ce que
l'on ressent lorsque l'on perd fort la
peau d'un animal où j'ai pris un coup de
corne comme d'autres et ça m'a pas
empêché de continuer et de me tenir
debout je n'ai pas souffert
ça me fait pas mal parce
qu'effectivement je suis en adrénaline
par contre je suis resté trois mois
ensuite à la maison sans pouvoir torre
est en rééducation et là ça m'a fait
souffrir de ne pas pouvoir retourner
dans l'arène c'est plus cet esprit-là
que que j'ai l'as eu la sensation
pendant pendant 20 ans de retrouver avec
les taureaux qui était dans ce combat
autant que moi balleux pelleter sur la
souffrance
ouais mais ce qui est intéressant dans
l'intervention la d2 pro corrida c'est
qu'il parle toujours de leurs
perspectives ils ne voient pas souffrir
et certains même via nice donc dit que
s'il voyait les animaux souffrir
à ce moment là le spectacle lui
éclairé et la question n'est pas est ce
que je vois la souffrance des questions
c'est un peu une réflexion qu'il faut
avoir c'est ce qu'il ya de la souffrance
derrière ce spectacle le fait de ne pas
avoir la souffrance ne veut pas dire
rien n'a pas et si on prend l'analogie
des boxeurs quand on regarde un match de
boxe
on peut ne pas avoir de souffrances on
peut être aimé le spectacle de boxe et
on peut aimer le courage la ténacité où
l'agilité des boxeurs il n'empêche que
les boxeurs quand même quand ils
reçoivent un certain nombre de coups
souffre sinon il ne s'écoule rep ah
sinon il ne gagnera pas un cas irait la
bataille vis-à-vis de l'autre dont je
pense qu'il faut dans ce débat et je
prends ça va revenir souvent il faut
arrêter de parler de celui qui regarde
uniquement quand il y à une interaction
entre un animal est un être humain ou
même que ce soit entre des êtres humains
il faut prendre les deux points de vue
et là le point de vue du taureau il n'a
pas du tout été évoquée et il est
évident que plus pur appât pour le
taureau a pas une partie de plaisir
comme ça de se faire maltraiter par un
sur une dans une arène donc je pense que
la partie on met le taureau un petit peu
au centre de la réflexion ou en tout cas
d' un des éléments de la réversion la
corrida commence à poser problème
alors on mettra le taureau centre de la
réflexion mais je voudrais qu'on reste
quand même un temps encore avec ce que
ressent le public parce qu'il est très
important pour savoir si on doit
interdire ou abolir la corrida de savoir
ce que c'est parce que selon que c'est
un jeu un sport un sacrifice ou un art
on ne la voit pas de la même manière on
ne l'interdira pas pour les mêmes
raisons
alors laquelle grande question c'est
savoir si le public s'amuse
de ce qu'ils voient est ce qui est
notamment de la souffrance dont vous
parlez est ce qu'il s'en amusait ce
qu'il s'en repaît c'est très important
dans la façon qu'on a de considérer la
corrida alors c'est quoi un jeu ea
sports c'est du sacrifice humain c'est
ces religieux ou où c'est de l'art pour
moi ce n'est pas un jeu c'est une fête
c'est un art et le public
à mon avis ne vient pas s'amuser à la
corrida
il vient se divertir il vient voir la
mort parce que c'est le seul art dans
lequel la mort soit présente réellement
mais il suffit de venir dans les arènes
pour voir le public être graves être
solennel il est pas du tout là haut
contrairement à la légende il est pas du
tout là en berne dans train de boire des
bières et de rigoler j'ai jamais vu j'ai
dû voir des corridas seulement moi ça
fait un an que je connais la corrida
j'ai jamais vu de gens s'amuser et au
moment de la mise à mort la mort du
taureau de cet animal qui est adoré
vénéré par une partie du peuple du sud
ce moment est grave ce moment à un poids
et je pense que ce les gens qui sont là
ont conscience de l'importance de la
mort de cet animal adoré contrairement à
tous les gens qui ont qui mangent de la
viande et qui n'en a rien à la
date de la manière dans le temps dont
l'animal est tué et d'ailleurs ce qui
est intéressant
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez de 7,7
cette histoire il ya quelques années un
an ou deux un supermarché avait vendu
des gibiers en barquette
il y avait des lapins non dépecer des
lièvres nous dépecer en barquette savait
créer un scandale c'était un scandale et
la direction du supermarché s'était
excusé et avait retiré
c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'on voyait
l'animal ce qu'on voyait l'animal et on
avait conscience de manger un animal
mort on voyait la mort on voyait qu'on
avait tué un animal
or dans la corrida évidemment la mort
est là elle est mise en scène elle est
acceptée on la regarde en face
starozinski
alors plusieurs choses les d'abord la
mort quand on veut l'approcher
c'est très facile surtout en ce moment
on va dans les hôpitaux et des gens qui
meurent y en a énormément
donc moi j'ai pas besoin de ça c'est
pour ça que si je n'aime pas la corrida
et puis il ya aussi et on à julien
lescarret aujourd'hui qui est là je ne
sais pas s'il va être du même avis que
moi mais les aficionados prétendent
qu'ils veulent tous éviter la blessure
et la mort du torero mais il ne cesse
d'exploser son corps est pour moi la
corrida est condamnable du point de vue
de l'animal mais aussi du point de vue
de l'homme parce que j'ai très souvent
vu à des corridas
même s'il ne suis pas allée très souvent
mais j'ai souvent vu des gens attendre
le moment et je pèse mes mots et se
créer cette espèce de petite frayeur
le torero a fait un pas de côté est ce
que parce qu'il a priori ce qui va pas
le dernier
ça va ça me fait penser un petit peu à
ces accidents
chaque fois qu'il ya un accident au bord
de la route les gens besoin d'aller voir
alors effectivement les gens ont besoin
d'aller voir la mort et je pense que en
fait à travers la corrida c'est aussi ce
que beaucoup ont recherché puis à une
deuxième chose je suis ni moins un
donc comme je connais bien l'hymne gelé
bien le public efficio nahd savait avant
d'aller la baisse maintenant de la
corrida et beaucoup de gens la plupart
des gens ne sont pas des aficionados ils
vont à la corrida parce qu'il faut y
aller tu as vu qu'il y avait la corrida
et elle était alliée comment tu crois
qu'elle est toujours avec intel dont je
crois que les plus réculés elle a
divorcé
voilà c'est ça aussi c'est une espèce de
snobisme dont il faut être très
conscient alors bien sûr je lis à lescar
et est-ce que vous avez l'impression
parfois de enfin quand vous étiez torero
de faire encore les jeux du cirque au
fond d'être là pour que pour que les
belles dames et les
il est riche messieurs et
vous admire en train de risquer votre
vie moffou comme un gladiateur des temps
modernes et est ce que vous êtes
conscient a l'air de dire clairement aux
risques que ceux parmi ceux qui vous
regarde y'a pas que des connaisseurs il
ya aussi des gens qui sont là qu il a
tout simplement parce qu'on leur a dit
qu'il fallait être là franchement je
vais pas la contredire je crois qu'elle
a tout à fait raison et que pour
participer à beaucoup de spectacles
sportifs culturels ou dans divers
domaines je retrouve les mêmes personnes
partout dans tous les milieux dans tous
les spectacles
alors on en fait tous partie en plus ce
qu'ils étaient en 2006 ça se trouve elle
a des amis des gens autour d'elle ou
peut-être plus amie avec ces gens là qui
ont aimé ou qui aiment encore ou qui
aimeront la corrida c'est aussi une
humanité qui se dresse dans ses arènes
là on va tous assisté à quelque chose
qui va nous réunir qui va nous émouvoir
et effectivement on a quand même en
règle générale et yann et se disait très
bien un public qui est extrêmement
respectueuse qui solennelle bien sûr
qu'il va assister à quelque chose
d'intense de graves parfois aussi se
divertir bien sûr mais c'est admirable
d'avoir encore des hommes qui sont
capables de mettre leur vie en péril
pour peut-être satisfaire quelques uns
peut être pour réjouir d'autres
peut-être pour réconforter encore
certain face à la mort et puis pour
reparler effectivement de la mort plus
précisément pour l'avoir vécu aussi
comme j'imagine tout le monde ici autour
du plateau dans le manière personnelle
mois la corrida m'a permis de vivre la
mort de mes proches beaucoup plus
sereinement et beaucoup mieux parce que
sans doute je l'avait approché deux
tableaux pelletier dirait la question de
savoir si c'est un spectacle une fête si
c'est un amusement un événement solennel
toutes ces questions là ne sont pas
vraiment importante c'est la loi
considère que les sévices graves
les actes de cruauté envers les animaux
sont interdits
c'est l'article 521 1 du code pénal ces
deux lois s'appliquent dans la quasi
totalité de la france à l'exception du
sud
c'était donc une dérogation spéciale qui
n'a aucune justification rationnelle
donc la plupart de la citoyens français
considèrent que c'est un acte de ce sont
des actes de cruauté qui doivent être
interdits il faudrait appliquer la loi
de façon cohérente à l'ensemble du
territoire que certaines personnes y
voit un moment solennel de se retrouver
de vivre des émotions de je sais pas ou
de se rencontrer
c'est une chose mais comme on dit c'est
pas c'est pas ça la question importante
la question importante c'est toujours
quand il ya une activité là qui implique
des animaux est ce qu'il ya des actes de
cruauté ou oui ou non la france
considère que c'est il y à des actes de
cruauté donc ça devrait être interdit et
on peut même aller plus loin vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que les actes de
cruauté sont interdits mais il faut
savoir aussi qu'il est interdit de tuer
un animal sans nécessité en france c'est
l'article r 6 155 du code pénal
on n'a pas le droit de tuer un animal
sans nécessité donc si on appliquait la
loi de façon cohérente à l'ensemble du
territoire on interdirait la choroïde la
corrida demain quel que soit le plaisir
que peuvent avoir certaines personnes à
la regarder
je sais pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous parce que sur cet angle là
précisément on estime que la mort du
taureau dans une arène est équivalente à
la mort d'une vache à l'abattoir et que
en fait il va ensuite d'ailleurs à
l'abattoir c'est là qu'il est conduit et
que donc c'est honteux on considère que
ça tombe sous la même la même loi en
réalité mais les avais réseau ce qui le
différencie la corrida de tout le reste
c'est effectivement la mise en scène de
la cruauté et ça c'est interdit on a
fait une exception pour la corrida au
nom de la tradition
là on aurait une chose quand même c'est
que la spa alors je j'ai noté comme ça
la spa a accusé le grand matador de
toros et bastien casteilla de sévices
graves ou actes de cruauté envers un
animal
domestique ou captifs et accusé la ville
de béziers et le directeur des arènes de
béziers robert margé de complicité ils
ont été relaxés par le tribunal de
béziers et le tribunal de béziers a
observé que l'élevage apparaît en
réalité beaucoup plus respectueux de
l'animal tant dans le rapport à l'homme
que dans la nourriture apporter les
soins prodigués que pour la plupart des
animaux de consommer de consommation
humaine et donc la sp a été déboutée et
condamnée à payer 4500 euros de frais de
justice
c'est quand même intéressant de lire et
vous le justifier comment le fait que
l'élevage de taureaux de taureaux de
combat qui sont destinés donc à mourir
dans l'arène vous semble avouer et au
tribunal de béziers visiblement vous
semble avoue bien plus bien plus
bienveillants au fond que d'apporter
quel autre élevage
c'est à dire que moi je n'y connaissais
rien je suis allé voir une corrida
j'ai vu le contraire de ce qu'on a
expliqué je suis allé dans les élevages
et j'ai vu des animaux dans des
conditions de vie absolument a eu 6
nantes dans un confort absolument
incroyable et c'est surtout que j'ai
compris en intéressant à ces animaux que
le combat était dans leurs gènes
c'est à dire que les taureaux se battent
entre eux dans une violence mille fois
supérieure à celles qu'ils connaissent
dans l'arène face à l'homme et donc moi
ce que je vois c'est un taureau donner
quelque chose
naturellement et je vois l'homme tiré de
la nature de cette bête quelque chose
qui va le faire grandir et on ne le
contraignant en rien c'est c'est pour
cela que je pense que la corrida est
tolérable et qu'elle est nécessaire pour
d'autres raisons
alors on a on arrive là au point de vue
du taureau on va l'aborder juste après
on doit faire une pause on commencera
une dernière petite question par rapport
à ce que vient de soulever yanis tézier
dit ces élevages de taureaux vous avez
bien que si demain on abolit la corrida
s'en sera fini des taureaux puisque pull
jamais personne ne va leur donner des
hectares comme on leur donne aujourd'hui
oui peuvent gambader librement sans
jamais rencontrer un homme d'ailleurs en
tout cas un homme à pied tout ça s'en
sera fini puisque pourquoi leur donner
autant de place alors qu'ils n'auront
plus aucune utilité
sinon d'aller à l'abattoir directement
sans passer par la reine
vous êtes bien consciente salle thomas
lepeltier la question je penserai en
quoi ça un problème de faire disparaître
une race de taureaux cédera ça a été
inventé par des humains et elle ne tient
là n'existe effectivement que parce
qu'on les envoie dans des arènes mais ce
n'est pas un problème si demain la race
avait à disparaître c'est pas du temps
même quand vous avez des êtres vivants
des êtres com de com des torts ou de
quels que soient les animaux ta question
n'est pas de savoir s'ils vont continuer
la race où l'espèce va continuer ici
c'est la façon dont vous comporter avec
c'est avec cet individu est ce que les
individus qui existe là vous allez les
maltraiter ou pas imaginons que demain
on vont développe une race de chien et
que cette race ne puisse exister que
parce que on les fait faire se battre
entre eux a géré tout le monde
trouverait ça très cruel que cette race
de chien de destiner que finalement le
combat de deux chiens
donc on dirait non il n'est pas question
de développer une race de chien de
combat juste pour le plaisir des
spectateurs et on abolit rsa tout de
suite sans hésiter mais là puisqu'on a
un petit peu oublié l'origine de la
corrida on oublie on a l'impression que
c'est une tradition donc on est tous
derrière le dos de la tradition on a
créé cette race et cédera c'est
effectivement n'existe que parce que ils
vont se battre à après mais je veux dire
c'est si on faisait pour des chiens on
trouverait ça scandaleux
je vois pas pourquoi on ne devra pas
trouvé sa seconde et or ont mis à
l'écart et oui je vais faire une petite
rectification alors pas historique mais
c'est une race quand même autochtone
alors on n'a pas créé comme pour faire
des combats de chiens
effectivement aujourd'hui et y aller
c'est très bien dit les élevages sont
faits en ce sens il ya un vrai respect
avec au système une biodiversité
magnifique où les taureaux peuvent
grandir et être observés et je souhaite
bien du courage à ceux qui croiseraient
leur chemin
on ne fait pas les années
écoulée c'est dans ses choix j'ai eu
quelques exemples malheureuse de
taureaux qui ont tué des touristes qui
se promenaient au bord du chemin
ça reste un animal sauvage et très
dangereux cet animal qu'on aime qu'on a
préservé jusqu'à aujourd'hui et pour
contredire monsieur le pen team je veux
surtout pas qu'ils disparaissent au
contraire je les trouve fantastique ces
animaux ce sont des dieux des rois pour
nous ce sont des animaux qu'il faut
absolument préserver et le malheur
d'aujourd'hui si de vouloir tout donner
ce ticket tout ramener à l'humain moi je
trouve ça magnifique d'avoir encore ces
animaux sauvages et qu'on puisse aussi
encore les affronter et peut-être risqué
notre mort et évidemment apporter
l'amour au bout de ce combat
la rolls royce qui nous reste juste une
minute elle dit mais d'abord harass
taureaux de combat n'existe pas c'est
uniquement l'expression partielle du
patrimoine génétique de l'aurochs donc
ça il faudrait un petit peu que tout le
monde s'en souviennent et arrête de
raconter n'importe quoi ça n'existe pas
taureaux de combat n'existe pas ça a été
baptisé par l'homme et de toutes façons
ensuite on sait très bien que maintenant
depuis la race des deux pays domec les
toros ingénierie des toros adjani en
piste parce qu'ils se sont des taureaux
faible parce qu'il n'existe plus
d'hectares avec des pétards et des
pétards et pendant la corrida
on a très bien vu ce qui s'est passé les
éleveurs ont trop de taureaux pourquoi
parce que bien sûr les choses se
reproduire donc c'était uniquement créés
par l'angle est là où ils se sont
plaints parce que un toro de 10000 euros
il est obligé d'en mettre 90 % à
l'abattoir donc il faut arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi
voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire
sur ce sujet et puis ici on sait bien
que vous soyez arrêté jusqu'à gaspé pile
pour la poche vous redonne la parole
juste après on fait une pause et on
continue il ne cesse d'augmenter et
devrait atteindre cette année 9 4% du
pib français
un record on parle bien sûr du déficit
public quand vous avez un déficit de
près de 10% et que vous allez faire
peut-être quatre peut-être 5% de
croissance
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant eh bien
vous êtes en récession de 6 quoi en gros
c'est ça que ça veut dire mais plutôt
dans une stratégie de deux dirigeants
lahlou 15 après moi le déluge
mais le déluge s'il va finir par arriver
si l'on continue à voir ce clip de
désinvolture et d'insouciance vis-à-vis
de la situation de nos finances
publiques qui a beaucoup d'activités qui
sont plus à gauche bras et qui le jour
où il n'y a plus de n'y a plus d' aides
vont s'effondrer vont continuer à
espérer dans l'efficacité d'un plan de
relance qui est totalement inappropriée
et totalement perpendiculaires aux
besoins de l'économie française
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés une découverte qui avaient été
faites par des gens qui travaillaient
sur les halles que kb identifié chez les
algues des protéines qui répondent à la
lumière et entraîne la formation d'un
courant électrique comme le font les
neurones et comme le feront normalement
les cellules sensibles à la lumière dans
la rétine pas ce qu'il va dire qu'il
voit un peu c'est il distingue la
lumière il distingue quoi exactement par
le patient et le pain par exemple de
reconnaître les passages protégés dans
la rue de détecter des objets différents
objets de petite taille de vente à
plusieurs niveaux en face d'eux les
comtés de les attraper et comme c'est un
patient qui ne voyait plus rien depuis
une quinzaine d'années c'est déjà une
source d'espoir c'est évidemment pas un
point définitif du parcours c'est une
étape franchie
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur la corrida avec
yanis et ziani qui est le responsable du
dossier
viva la corrida qui est en couverture du
dernier numéro de closer avec la re
starozinski qui est présidente de
l'alliance anti corrida avec julien
escaré ancien torero et avec thomas
lepeltier philosophe et historien des
des sciences alloresto sur l'animal et
je vous redonne la parole tout de suite
car starozinski
on voit ça souvent le taureau comme un
animal une fois qu'il est dans l'arène
n'a aucune chance ou presque
torturé par des hommes en habit de
lumière qui eux ne prennent aucun risque
c'est comme ça que vous voyez vous non
c'est faux
moi personnellement je ne mettrai pas
devant un animal de 500 kilos parce
qu'effectivement il ya des risques mais
comme l'a si bien dit julien lescarret
et puis commencer par rapport aux
statistiques les risques sont moindres
il meurt très peu de trop pour une
proportion et nous gigantesque de
taureaux attention on ne fasse pas dire
ce que je n'ai pas dit je ne compare pas
la mort de l'homme et la mort de
l'animal
loin de là ils se sont simplement des
statistiques dans l'arène les taureaux
sans avant d'entrer dans l'arène et moi
c'est aussi de ça que j'aimerais donc on
parle une proportion non négligeable de
tours sont diminués par tout un tas de
procéder ça les aficionados savent en
général c'est à la demande de certains
toreros donc je ne citerai pas les noms
ou à la demande de certains
organisateurs et organisatrices dont je
ne citerai pas les noms
ça se fait encore on lui les cornes du
taureau mais omet de l'éliminer sur 1 cm
on les limes sur un très grand nombre de
centimètres
parfois jusqu'à 7 cm il faut savoir que
pour le taureau les licornes me
permettent de se repérer dans l'espace
et un taureau qui ne puisse la paix rhdp
dans l'espace à de grosses difficultés
il ya aussi une proportion non
négligeable
l'autoroute qui est drogué ces études
ont été faites à salamanque et ailleurs
oui oui des taureaux qui sont drogués et
qui sont piquées avec des
tranquillisants soit avec quand ils sont
trop faibles
quand on se rend compte qu'ils sont
faibles et qui vont pas jouer le jeu
il ya avec des produits qui voit un
petit peu les dopés et tout ça
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on m'en parle
et j'aimerais justement que j'ai dit a
déclaré on parle alors julien on vous
écoute c'est vrai que ces accusations
reviennent régulièrement
de plus en plus souvent d'ailleurs et
moi-même pour avoir été assisté à des
corridas que je n'avais pas vu depuis
longtemps j'ai trouvé que le niveau
avait carrément baissé il faut bien le
dire enfin que il y avait des animaux
qui me paraissaient suspects qui tenait
à peine sur leurs jambes
j'en ai été assez assez choqué qu'en
pensez vous en tout cas je trouve que
kar savuth qui ferait une excellente
aficionada puisqu'elle se soucie
effectivement que le taureau soit dans
les meilleures conditions possibles et
aux arènes et je trouve ça très bien
effectivement c'est très important pour
nous aussi que les bonnes conditions on
a échappé aux sacs de sable et aux vases
in dans les yeux qu'on entend encore un
petit peu mais ce qui est étrange c'est
que et d'ailleurs j'en fais encore
l'invitation aujourd'hui de les inviter
dans les élevages et suivre toute la
corrida et toute la journée alors être
insupportable pour leurs yeux ou pour
leur sensibilité
en tout cas ils sont cordialement
invités et on peut trouver tous les
éleveurs de france ou d'espagne qui vont
les invités avec grand plaisir pour
découvrir un taureau campo les suivre
dans le camion qui va les amener aux
arènes voir le tirage au sort le matin
voir dans quelles conditions ils
arrivent aux arènes et dans quelles
conditions et sans combattre ce serait
avec grand plaisir
elle verra de ses propres yeux plutôt
que lire des choses qui souvent
malheureusement ce que vous les entendez
par là qu'en fait tout ça n'existe pas
ou c'est lui que c'est véritablement
aimé qu'l de tic
alors oui effectivement c'est
anecdotique mais ça existe
il ya certes un spectacle où
effectivement les cornes des taureaux
sont parfois protégé même dans les
spectacles portugais notamment le combat
cheval
il ya aussi des pratiques effectivement
où on lime certaines parties des
taureaux parce que les cordes son
cabinet
malgré un homme qui se bat kevin campo
etc les décors qui sont on appelle ça
vescovi et ses patients le voit bien
avec des petites bout de corde comme ça
qui explosent et donc il faut nettoyer
tout ça pour que le taux soit le plus
présentable possible et pour l'avoir
vécu je vous garantis que les coups de
cornes des toreros sont près par contre
mais pourtant car à raison les cornes
des taureaux sont des radars si on les
limons fausse le radar et il va y va il
va il va être moins dangereux pour vous
et c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison
que on soupçonne parfois les
organisateurs où les toreros de vouloir
qu on line les cornes des taureaux où on
va les drogués pour qu'il soit plus
faible et parfois sur les drogues trop
malheureusement ils ont du mal à courir
dans l'arène et ça se voit mais tout ça
d'après vous c'est avec deux titres n
existe pas alors tout ce qui est de la
drogue je peux vous garantir moi j'en ai
aucune idée je lis jamais vu je ne sais
pas du tout à ce niveau là ce qu'il en
est en tout cas je pense que ce serait
terrible et perturbateur parce qu un
taureau en tout cas un torero préparer à
affronter un taureau dans tous ses
moyens et impute c'est sa capacité de
combattre serait j'imagine perturbée par
un animal qui serait pas le même je ne
sais pas quels seraient les effets de la
drogue
pour ce qui est des cordons oui
effectivement ça arrive notamment
beaucoup pour les entraînements pour les
pratiques que l'on fait en privé parce
qu'on fait aussi des combats en privé où
on se protège en quelque sorte mais on
coupe les cornes
histoire de vraiment pouvoir se protéger
et de ne pas avoir la pointe ce n'est
pas le cas dans les arènes lors des
spectacles du trot sont en pointe même
si les ont été comme je voulais dit
arrangé pour que la pointe reste la plus
dangereuse possible aussi pour
l'intégrité du spectacle le mâle
pelletier l'acea c'est un débat
technique on va pas pouvoir résoudre
tout de suite savoir il faudrait qu'il y
ait une enquête sérieuse qui soit faite
je veux bien croire ce que nous dit
notre intervenant
mais il n'en reste pas mois même si le
taureau n'est pas amoindrie
la question reste toujours pourquoi se
permettant de faire cette cruauté à
l'encontre d'un taureau alors qu'on ne
se le permettrait pas déjà dans d'autres
régions de france et qu'on se le
permettrait pas avec d'autres animaux il
ya toujours le problème de la cruauté
auquel les
jean les aficionados ne répondent pas
ils bête ça derrière soi l'argument de
la tradition soit l'argument du
spectacle soit une dimension un petit
peu personnel de défi contre la nature
mais c'est toujours sans prendre en
compte le point de vue du taureau le
taureau il préfère vivre dans son champ
il préfère qu'on lui laisse la paix il a
pas envie qu'on lui plante d épée dans
le dos donc quelque part il ya une
absence de réponse et c'est toujours par
rapport à l'individu qui maltraitent
l'autoroute les aficionados e place et
ne prennent jamais en compte la position
du taureau et je pense que une réflexion
éthique consiste à prendre en compte
tous les points de vue et je pense que
si on prend en compte tous les points de
vue on peut très bien comprendre assez
rapidement que le taureau n'a pas envie
d'être là dans l'arène
alors ça c'est la question fondamentale
pour les anti corridas il considère que
le taureau n'a aucune envie d'être dans
l'arène que si on lui laissait il
rentrerait dans le toril
et ensuite il rentrerait dans son champ
les partisans de la corrida les
aficionados disent que c'est dans la
nature du taurou de se battre qu'il est
très heureux en arrivant dans l'arène
que toute façon dans son champ s'il
voyait une locomotive arrivé à toute
allure une faune serait dessus parce
qu'il est ils font sur tout ce qui bouge
et qui donc il est dans la nature du
combat du taureau de combattre c'est ce
que vous pensez vous bah moi c'est ce
que je pense et je pense que c'est un
sac la corrida et aurélie est tolérable
c'est-à-dire qu'elles tirent du taureau
quelque chose qui n'est pas contre sa
nature ça n'a rien à voir que lorsqu'on
fait danser sur de l'orgue de barbarie
non pas du tout mais même si en fait je
ne vois pas les qu'il va l'équivalent de
quelque chose qu on tirerait d'un animal
qui qui ne causerait rien de riz vous
voyez ce que je veux dire je trouve pas
le mot là c'est à dire que c'est
je n'ai pas d'autres exemples de quelque
chose qu'on arrive à tirer d'un animal
de cette manière sans contraindre
l'animal c'est à dire que je suis pas
certain que la vache à lait envie de
rentrer à l'établé de se faire à tirer
cependant je sais combien de temps j'ai
regardé par exemple des vidéos de l214
juste avant de venir je me suis quand
même je n'avais jamais regardé j'ai vu
des choses d'une atrocité mais
absolument épouvantable c'est une des
dons sociaux que
fait elle 200 cas mais c'est formidable
mais c'est formidable mais c'est
écoeurant c'est à vomir c'est à dire que
ce qui se passe dans les abattoirs vous
voulez dire voilà mais mais mais cette
horreur que j'ai éprouvé à voir ses
vidéos
je ne vais pas éprouvé dans les arènes
et je vous assure que je sais pas
concevable 14000 personnes acceptent
qu'on torture avec ce mot torture et aux
tortures un animal pendant 20 minutes
c'est pas concevable franchement c'est
pas qu'on se marre le quart d'heure un
quart d'heure c'est pas concevoir
minutes qui tuerait l'homme
ils sont très intelligents les taureaux
savard d'heure ils apprennent plus de
choses qu'un homme dans sa vie en mai
julien sava pages entre l'entrée du
taureau est là et la morgue du taux et
de la mort du taureau ça peut pas
jusqu'à 20 minutes
non c'est un cas très rare d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure
madame tandis qu'à dix minutes en mourir
il ya d'un règlement qui fait qu'on ne
peut pas aller au delà de quinze minutes
sinon rentrer le taureau dd on ne peut
pas aller au delà c'est le règlement qui
lui est ce que ça n'est pas parce que à
20 minutes qu'il vous tuerai à couture
parce qu'il aurait compris de vous
cacher derrière une cape
alors il y en a qui ont tué d'autres
torero avant les 20 minutes mais il y en
a qui au bout d'une demi-heure
effectivement deux s'aperçoivent de rien
ça dépend réellement de la personnalité
de chaque taureau et de la capacité de
chaque torero aussi à les affronter
d'accord je retiens ce que j'ai dit
qu'elle est une réponse
thomas lepeltier ce que vient de dire
yanis et ziani ya 10 6 à 10 est
scandalisé par ce qui se passe dans les
abattoirs
et pourtant j'imagine qu'il doit
continuer à manger de la viande on est
en france 65 millions de français qui
devaient être choqué par quand ils
voient des images de 214 et les français
continuent à manger de la viande donc le
fait qu' on est scandalisé par quelque
chose et qu'on continue comme à
perpétuer ce système là y'a rien de
cette chute l'illogisme mais c'est
quelque chose qui existe tout à fait
mais on en revient toujours à au
problème du jeu du gie e qui revient
yanis asiatiques ne voit pas la torture
ne voit pas la souffrance donc il dit je
ne vois pas la souffrance je ne vois pas
la torture donc tout va bien
c'est une incapacité de se mettre dans
la peau du taureau c'est une incapacité
de voir les intérêts du thouraud
l'intérêt le taureau il est comme tous
les animaux il veut sauver sa peau et
quelque part donc s'ils pouvaient saab
sauvé sa peau il le ferait il fait ce
qu'il peut pour sauver sa peau et donc
s'ils pouvaient fuir et fuiraient ou
même peut-être ils se battraient mais
non il éviterait ce genre de combat où
il est perdant quasiment d'avancé donc
c'est cette incapacité à se mettre dans
la peau du taureau qui et c'est cette
capacité au contraire toujours à parler
du jeu avoir le plaisir qu'on trouve à
quelque chose j'ai un plaisir à regarder
un spectacle
j'y vois des des mentions d'héroïsme j'y
vois des dimensions autres et comme on
veut des valeurs humaines là dedans mais
et donc on valorise ce ce spectacle mais
non agir la question est y revient
toujours
excusez moi de revenir sur sa le taureau
on le maltraite c'est interdit en france
de maltraiter un taureau comme on le
fait dans les cas rida pourquoi quelle
est la justification pour qu'on puisse
l'autorisé dans 11 départements français
on attend toujours une réponse alors le
seul argument qui est donné dans la loi
c'est l'argument de la tradition mais
vous savez très bien que l'argument de
la tradition n'a aucune valeur logique
rationnelle
autrement on peut tout justifier par la
tradition donc pourquoi la corrida est
elle interdite en france sauf dans le
département et y at il une explication
rationnelle à ça je l'attend toujours
julien lescarret
pour vous bien entendu il est dans la
nature du taureau de combattre et quand
vous le combattent et non seulement pas
l'impression de le torturer ni même de
l'assassiner vous le combat théo font
presque par amour alors pas par amour
j'ai aimé mes chiens j'ai aimé mes chats
j'aimais mes animaux domestiques qui
d'ailleurs je conçois malheur c sont des
réflexions des paysans et pas de
citadins mais de pouvoir élever des
animaux dans des appartements ou
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas de nature et qu'ils
peuvent pas courir et vivre libre c'est
un petit peu la même chose avec un
animal que je j'admire que je respecte
n'est pas que j'aime je ne ne portent
pas d'amour envers cet animal j'étais
anthropomorphisme et il ya un vrai débat
aussi d'art de vivre et de société et la
cour il a un quart de beaucoup de choses
alors beaucoup de valeurs humaines on
l'a dit moi j'essaie de ne pas me mettre
à la place des animaux en tous cas de
leur donner des caractéristiques
humaines
je garde cet esprit sauvage cet instinct
animal de se battre et si vous voulez
réellement savoir ce que pense en tout
cas comment réagissent et animaux il
suffit d'aller s'enfermer une semaine
dans un élevage en france ou en espagne
de vivre avec eux au quotidien de leur
nez à manger de les nourrir de les
soigner les andes servait de les parquer
et de vivre ça au quotidien vous allez
comprendre mieux que sacralisé sur un
quart d'heure finalement dans l'arène
bien que là encore on a la chance
d'avoir un animal différent des autres
qui a encore sauvage qui se bat pour ce
qu'il est pour sa nature profonde et
c'est pour ça que la corrida aujourd'hui
ça justifie mieux que n'importe quel
autre spectacle et que je pense qu'elle
a de beaux jours devant elle
c'est justement parce que on a un
taureau qui se bat et qui est dans sa
nature profonde
contrairement aux autres animaux
qu'aujourd'hui on fait disparaître ou
que on tue parfois sur la route aussi
comme les moustiques
ça dépend de la valeur et de l'échelle
qu'on place auxi par rapport aux animaux
enfin vous inscrire bon alors d'abord
plusieurs choses
yanis excusez-moi de vous appeler comme
ça que je connais pas vraiment bien
votre nom de famille si vous voulez
vraiment voir un animal qui n'est pas
contraint par ce que vous dites que le
taureau de corrida les contrats n'est
pas contre un mais bien sûr que si les
contrats les contraintes par la mode et
art il est contraint ensuite par là
français par tout ce qu'on lui fait pour
les faire baisser la tête donc c'est un
animal qui est contre
si vous voulez aller voir des gens qui
si le meilleur d'un animal le plus beau
d'un animal est alors allé voir une
course camarguaise et là il n'y a pas de
morts et là vous verrez que l'animal ne
veut pas sortir de la piste l'animal
entre en piste et tout ce qu'il veut
faire ses courses et l'homme et chercher
l'homme alors que le taureau le taureau
ou ne cherche pas l'homme le taureau dès
qu'il entre en piste
ils cherchent elles ici il cherche à
repartir ils cherchent une porte
il cherche une échappatoire ça n'a
absolument rien à voir alors s'il vous
plaît s'il échoue
allez le voir une course camarguaise
aller voir les au mont-blanc aller voir
des hommes courageux et là ça sera
différent et après il ya quelque chose
qui m'étonne aussi beaucoup c'est que je
viens les cervélo dit c'est un animal
sauvage etc
c'est très très bien qu'après il dit que
conna ît les voir qu'on aille voir
comment les nourrir
comment les soigne comme en mai s'est
nourrie par un animal sauvage si on
nourrit d'ailleurs au sens du code pénal
le taureau de corrida
le taureau qui est utilisé dans une
course de taureaux est un animal qu'on
s'est considéré comme un animal
domestique
ça c'est juste que je voulais dire et
quand j'ai parlé de dix minutes je
parlais des dix minutes difficiles les
cinq premières minutes
effectivement c'est très beau en
lorraine avec les passent le cap avec
tout ça les cinq premières minutes du
taureau quand il arrive dans l'arène
c'est après que ça se gâte
malheureusement et là ça dure environ 10
minutes entre eux
l'apic des banderilles et l'estocade et
quand vous avez parlé de 20 minutes
effectivement ça peut arriver en corrida
privé j'ai vu moi une corrida privé ce
qu'on appelle une corrida prévue
c'est bah c'est tout simple bois
biomasse dans mon jardin
si j'ai envie chanter 20 je peux très
bien me demander
ex torero ou quelqu'un qui s'y connaît
devenir je peux acheter quelques torrio
niveau en général
et puis je peux faire exercer des gens
avec quelqu'un et merguez je vois en
quelques tickets et n'importe qui peut
faire ça dans une zone de tradition
locale ininterrompue et alors là je dis
qu'il est bon là c'est quelque chose
cela s'est passé quelque chose de
monstrueux là à l'épée entre elle
ressort c'est absolument inimaginable
inimaginable de désolation je n'ai vu de
mes propres yeux dans un village qui
s'appelle francs que vous julien
lescarret se disait que je suis à la
retraite donc elle compatir moi par
contre pour les merguez et pour l'après
jeux je suis là s'il ya besoin
j'ai un bon bilan barre yanis et vie non
quand vous me c'est sûr venez voir quand
vous me dites venez voir les courses
camarguaises pour voir ce qu'on peut
tirer d'un animal alors là je vais
entrer dans quelque chose de moins
politiquement correct et qui peut être
ne niera pas dans les intérêts de la
corrida je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
évidemment on vient aux arènes pour voir
la grâce la beauté l'esthétisme mais
évidemment convient aux arènes je pense
aussi pour voir la mort et donc la
ritualisation évidemment la
ritualisation de cette mort nous permet
de voir la mort en face et de voir
comment on accepte la mort d'un être est
un taureau qu'on admire qu'on admire
vivant comment on accepte sa mort
évidemment que la mort et est importante
dans la corrida mais vous dites pour
aller au bout de votre raisonnement vous
dis que je n'ai pas le seul
beaucoup d'admirateurs de la corrida on
dit la même chose que la tauromachie au
fond a faites vous un homme meilleur
parce que tout à coup vous êtes mis à
avoir une représentation et donc vous
êtes mis à admirer le courage le
stoïcisme le contrôle de soi alors là je
parle du torero mais aussi
vous avez eu tout à coup plus de respect
pour la nature et pour le bien-être
animal
évidemment ça peut paraître choquant de
se dire que vous tout à coup pour et des
contres conscience du bien-être animal
en voyant un taureau dans une arène
bien sûr premièrement ça m'a rendue je
pense meilleur parce que j'ai vu des
hommes encourage absolument exemplaire
et en stoïcisme en contrôle de soi ça
c'est une première chose et ça m'a rendu
meilleur je pense parce que ça m'a
sensibilisé sur la vie de l'animal c'est
à dire que j'ai compris grâce notamment
au livre de francis wolff que
j'encourage tout le monde à lire qui
s'appelle philosophie de la corrida est
aussi à mes rencontres avec les éleveurs
de taureaux qui m'ont emmené dans les
hommes leur élevage qui montrait comment
il travaille et j'ai compris que les
animaux n'étaient pas des animaux que
chaque animal que chaque race était une
être différent et qu'il fallait traiter
les animaux
en tenant compte de leurs particularités
et de leur animalité propres et de leurs
instincts et de leurs instincts et la
stable pour vous du taureau c'est de
combattre mais je pense que l'instinct
du taureau et est de vivre libres
rebelle et de se battre et d'ailleurs il
le fait naturellement avec ses
congénères dans des proportions beaucoup
plus violente que qu'il ne veut que
celle dans laquelle nous fait là quaïda
thomas lepeltier là ils vous parlent de
du point de vue de l'animal et on est
dans une mystique complète du taureau il
faut bien comprendre la cette idée que
l'animal le toro sera un animal fait
pour combattre
c'est un petit peu absurde surtout les
animaux qu'ils soient vont en général se
défendre quand ils se sentent menacés où
ils vont attaquer si ce sont des
carnivores par exemple ils vont attaquer
là c'est différent pour trouver à manger
quand ce ne sont pas des carnivores ils
vont soit se battre pour la rivalité
sexuelle soit se battre parce qu'ils se
sentent menacés et ça c'est pas
uniquement le taureau donc que le
taureau soit dans des situations où il
est tendance à se battre ou les
tendances à charrat chargé c'est tout à
fait vrai ça serait vrai aussi pour le
bison ça serai prêt pour le rhinocéros
un vrai pour l'hippopotame tous les
animaux vont se défendre alors pourquoi
on fait pas des corridas de rhinocéros
pour qu'on fait pas des corridas
d'hippopotames et tout ça c'est il n'y a
pas de nature du taureau qui serait une
nature spéciale dans le règne animal qui
serait l'animal qui quelque part et
exulte où vit sa vie quand il combat non
un animal il combat soit pour manger
soit pour se défendre soit en termes de
rivalité sexuelle donc là on en a choisi
un historiquement pour une raison un peu
arbitraire on a choisi le taureau parce
qu'on en avait on avait des vaches chez
nous et puis voilà c'est tout et on l'a
mis au milieu d'une arène on s'est
aperçu que ben effectivement comme il a
peur il sait pas trop où aller
il charge et donc on a pu faire un
spectacle de cette charge je suis tout à
fait d'accord mais ça répond pas à une
nature spéciale du taureau on est dans
man mystique là qui ne répond à aucun
aucune réflexion et aux logiques donc
sur les animaux donc maintenant on est
toujours pareil on est dans l'arbitraire
cet animal qui va se défendre et qui va
avoir tendance à charger parce qu'il a
peur
bon ben on s'amuse un peu on s'amuse ou
mais d'autres vins sur d'autres valeurs
derrière d'héroïsme ou de prouver qu'on
a du courage ou quoi que ce soit on peut
même faire un art on peut dire qu'il ya
un art il ya une certaine beauté mais
comment on peut regarder des films des
films violents et on trouve qu'il ya une
beauté dans des films violents on peut
même regardé à la télévision des scènes
de combats de gladiateurs on peut
trouver ça beau aussi donc je ne nie pas
qu'il puisse y avoir une certaine beauté
et la question toujours c'est
effectivement on le fait aux dépens
quand même de l'individu l'individu le
taureau s'il charge c'est parce qu'il a
peur et préférerait ne pas avoir peur
être tranquillement dans son champ mais
paul le pelletier on arrive toujours à
la même question au fond c'est que ce
que vous reprochez
aux hommes et pas seulement la corrida
c'est de tuer des animaux me rien qu'on
ne tue plus les animaux or il se trouve
que depuis des millénaires on tue les
animaux et les animaux se tuent entre
eux aussi et nous tue parfois pour tous
là pour la même raison pour manger vous
voudriez qu'on mette fin à tout ça mais
pas seulement pour leurs taureaux au
fond pour les vagues on et lapins pour
l'époux le tout à l'heure vous m'avez
repris quand j'avais cité un article r 6
155 du code pénal l'article r r 6 155 du
code pénal je disais il était interdit
de tuer les animaux quand sans nécessité
alors effectivement ça pose un problème
déjà pour les animaux d'élevage
classique les animaux de rente que l'on
mange
puisqu'il n'y a pas de nécessité allez
tu es allé manger tu veux dire donc pas
on a oublié donc il ya effectivement une
incohérence fondamentale des êtres
humains dans leur rapport aux animaux
ils ont au fond d'eux-mêmes l'idée qu'il
faudrait arrêter de tuer les animaux
mais bon il ya des habitudes qui sont
prêts sur lesquels ils n'arrivent pas à
revenir
effectivement ça pose un problème jeu
est un animal que ce soit quand
séquences et il n'y a pas de nécessité
si vous vous amusez à tuer votre chien
comme ça la justice va vous condamnez
tuer l'animal sans nécessiter
sainte-suzanne devrait pas se faire et
même si vous le faites en spectacle
alors vous ont tué quelque part vous en
faites à un spectacle ça devrait pas se
faire non plus que le spectacle n'a je
voudrais rien ou ne lève rien à la
cruauté dire d'enlever la vie un animal
finalement qui n'aspirent qu'à vivre
comme comme nous nous touche
je viens à lescar et dernier mot le
spectacle justement donne beaucoup de
sens à tout cela ça n'a rien d'un acte
gratuit
malheureusement ces deux types de
sociétés pour aller dans le sens de
monsieur pelletier dont on lui
souhaiterai et que nous en tout cas que
moi personnellement je ne souhaite pas
parce que j'aime manger des animaux je
dis pas que ça justifie cela je ne
mangent pas de légumes donc ce serait
compliqué pour moi de survivre même si
certains disent comme un besoin de
vivres pour survivre se nourrir -
actionneront ce que ça quasiment donc ce
serait compliqué pour moi de survivre à
cela c'est un art de vivre cette
tauromachie pour nous elle est certes je
vais pas remettre les arguments de nos
traditions etc
mais l'utilité la nécessité c'est
l'essentiel de chacun c'est le plaisir
de chacun de vivre une histoire
familiale avec ma famille de la
transmettre
rien que ça j'ai 80 années à passer sur
cette terre dans le bonheur des uns et
des autres dans le bonheur de respecter
la nature qui m'entourent et de vivre et
de mourir ensuite claire starozinski
d'animaux une fois encore je suis un peu
étonné parce que julien lescarret il dit
qu'il aime les animaux qu'il adore les
animaux mais en fait il se nourrit que
de ça donc ça veut dire que yanis qu'il
cautionne ce qui se passe dans les
abattoirs
je voudrais d'ailleurs à ce sujet dire
que l'alliance anti corrida était partie
civile pour l'abattoir d'évident pour
l'abattoir d'alès et que nous avons fait
une grande campagne nationale au mois de
février contre l'abattage rituel dans
toutes les villes de france
donc on ne sait pas que la corrida mais
aussi des abattoirs est bien évidemment
celle de viande depuis très longtemps je
lui dis avant qu'on me le demande
donc je suis et très étonné que je viens
lescarret arriva à 1 se rendent se
débrouiller pour les aimez mais en même
temps aller manger surtout qu'il sait
très bien ce qu'elle puisse pas ce qui
se passe dans les abattoirs est il
d'ailleurs le condamne fermement grande
incohérence tout bord bien sûr les
animaux évidemment il faudrait qu'on
arrive à ne plus les bandes j'ai
d'ailleurs si je veux vous dire quelque
chose
au plan personnel je n'ai jamais été
aussi résistantes aux maladies que
depuis que je ne mange plus de viande
parce qu'on sait très bien que la viande
et ça a été prouvé scientifiquement
apporte énormément de toxines
l'organisme est allé quand ces échecs il
encore dit il n'y a pas très longtemps
donc je souhaite quand même je viens
lescar et de vivre 80 encore encore pas
mal d'années je ne sais pas quel âge il
a dit ce qu'il veut il ya 92 ans a cessé
mais s'il continue à manger de la viande
je ne sais pas s'il va arriver au bout
du compte une dernière phrase ya des cdd
je vais essayer de faire court mais en
tout cas pour conclure sur ce sujet je
voudrais dire que moi je fais du théâtre
je suis dans une quête de beauté de
grandeur de grâce que je ne trouve nous
quasiment plus au théâtre que je ne
trouve quasiment plus à l'opéra et que
dans les arènes cette grandeur cette
grâce ce tragique m'a sauté aux yeux
pour moi les toreros sont les derniers
grands tragédiens sont les derniers
grands acteurs qui accepte la mort qu'il
affronte qui vont au devant de la
lumière de la mort et je pense que ce
n'est pas du tout un acte gratuit de
tuer le taureau
parce que on sait que c'est pour offrir
à tout ce public qui vient voir les
arènes car les arènes plein darren son
plein on offre à ce public ses
sentiments ses grand sentiment tragique
pour ne trouve plus nulle part ailleurs
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]